jetzt kommen wir zu einem ganz anderen
thema tod nach der narkose spritze in
einer zahnarztpraxis stirbt am 29
september die kleine emilia es war die
entscheidung der familie die bilder der
kleinen tochter zu veröffentlichen denn
sie sind entsetzt darüber was mit ihr
passiert ist ja wir sehen hier emilia
vier jahre als sie lächelt lebens lustig
doch jetzt jetzt ist sie tot mit nur
vier jahren gestorben nach einer narkose
in einer kinder zahnarztpraxis in
kronberg die trauer ist unendlich groß
dort nach unseren informationen sollen
noch mindestens drei weitere kinder
schwer verletzt in die klinik gekommen
sein wie konnte das passieren
ja dazu gehen wir jetzt an den ort des
geschehens nach kronberg dass es im
taunus bei frankfurt am main wir
schalten zu unserer bild reportern
claudia de chaillot claudia kunz einmal
stand jetzt ist diese zahnarztpraxis
weiterhin geöffnet also gehen da noch
leute ein und aus
hier in der kleinstadt kronberg bei
frankfurt sind die menschen erschüttert
und schockiert über den tod der kleinen
emilia eltern erzählen uns dass es kaum
anderes gesprächsthema gibt und dass man
kaum etwas anderes denken können was sie
nicht fassen können ist dass die praxis
immer noch geöffnet ist und dass
patienten hier immer noch behandelt
werden also wir sind heute vorbei
gegangen es ist alles als ob nichts
geschehen wäre die fenster sind hell
erleuchtet am empfang ist jemand selbst
in dem zimmer wo vermutlich emilia
behandelt wurde werden wieder patienten
behandelt die staatsanwaltschaft
frankfurt hat inzwischen aber mitgeteilt
dass gegen die behandelnden zahnärzte
und dem behandelten anästhesisten wegen
fahrlässiger tötung ermittelt wird und
zudem weit drei andere kleine kinder
zeitgleich behandelt wurden und
ebenfalls schwer verletzt wurden dass
dort wegen fahrlässiger körperverletzung
ermittelt wird weiß man irgendwie
schauen was bei der behandlung von
emilia schief gelaufen sein könnte
nach unseren informationen gehen die
ermittler inzwischen davon aus dass das
narkosemittel verunreinigt gewesen sein
könnte das würde bedeuten dass ein und
dasselbe mittel oder die gleiche flasche
für viel zu viele patienten für eine zu
langen zeitraum genutzt wurde um ganz
schlicht geld zu sparen und das in einer
kleinstadt wo millionäre schöne und im
normalfall in reichere leute wohnen und
zwar die dulisch vor den toren
frankfurts
ich habe mich gewundert dass er
überhaupt narkosen mit narkosen
gearbeitet wird bei diesem zahnarzt
völlig normal oder tatsächlich seltsam
erfahrene kinder zahnärzte haben uns
auch erklärt dass leider viel zu oft in
normalen zahnarztpraxen kinder unter
vollnarkose behandelt werden das wird
bedeutet auch dass nicht so erfahrene
anästhesisten am werk sind die auch in
krisensituationen bisweilen falsch
handeln oder auch zu spät den notarzt
verständigen in diesem fall muss es so
gewesen sein dass ein notarzt fast tote
weil er viel zu spät informiert wurde
und demzufolge vielleicht auch im hier
deshalb starb es ist unfassbar tragisch
sagt uns einmal was wollen jetzt die
eltern
wir haben so oft den letzten tagen mit
der familie von emilia gesprochen und
die nehmen ist es wirklich ein
herzensanliegen dass die
verantwortlichen zur rechenschaft
gezogen werden und
der tod von emilia gesund wird ja und
wir werden hierbei mit live alles dafür
tun dass das tatsächliche ausreichend
aufgeklärt wird diese erschreckende fall
danke an unsere bild reporterin claudia
d